the missile struck the market in the
center of the city as it was busy with
people video uploaded to social media
showing a scene of devastation
this is the site of the attack says the
man taking this video the Central Market
was hit many dead many wounded
later video appeared to show police
officers taking away body bags
located on the route to the war-torn
city of bakmut it is still around 20
kilometers from the front line this is
the worst loss of civilian life in a
single attack in many weeks and was
immediately condemned by Ukrainian
president felodimir zielinski as an act
of utter in humanity
those who know the city can clearly say
it's civilian and there is no military
base anywhere near
it came as U.S Secretary of State
Anthony blinken was beginning a visit to
the capital Kiev providing Ukraine with
a much needed show of support from its
most important overseas backer
in the week that the government here is
still reeling from the sacking of
Defense Minister Alexi reznikov amid
corruption scandals birthday
with the three-month-old
counter-offensive still making slow
progress
and amid deep-rooted anxiety about the
prospect of next year's U.S elections
threatening long-term support Rob
McBride Al Jazeera privy Ukraine
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera